[Music]
hey y'all happy sunday we're past time
and jenny's already yelling at me well
you know
i even got to get you got a clock in the
room and it's like i have to come up and
get you like every single time i was
listening to public enemy even though
you know yeah that's when the that's
when the show starts and you keep your
[ __ ] together this is a public enemy and
i had to get some root beer and then
yeah and then like he'll sit here for
three minutes and then he'll be like oh
wait i have to go to the bathroom or oh
wait i have to go get a drink and like
[ __ ] like i'm like why do you leave
everything into the last goddamn minute
i'm a man it's like you had plenty of
time you've been back for like 45
minutes you have plenty of time to get
prepared yeah it's just i don't know i
like to start things on time you know
i'm just saying
all right so today we are talking about
dark man now the reason we're talking
about this is because
um is because
uh sorry i got distracted um she's from
from you yelling
well i'm used to her making a noise it's
like it's a lot less distracting that's
a lot less distracting than you yelling
but um yeah so
shutter just added the whole dark man
trilogy
a couple weeks back so i had actually
been wanting to do we're gonna do a
movie retrospective i put it in the poll
but i don't think it ever won but then i
was like [ __ ] it i kind of want to watch
it again
um you would probably you had never seen
them right
you no i've seen them oh i didn't think
you'd seen that no i'd seen them i saw
the first one i haven't seen the other
two but we're gonna do the other two as
well because they have the whole trilogy
i saw i saw the other i saw the first
one many times the other two i don't
remember that much
i remember that they weren't as good i
remember tw and up two being okay
but i remember [ __ ] three not being
that good but we'll see well two and
three went were direct to video even
though i have to say that dark man and
this came out in 1990 it was pretty
financially successful it wasn't like a
blockbuster but i think it only cost
like 14 15 million to make and it made
like 50 million
so
you know it was successful enough that
they made like two sequels to it but
both of the sequels went direct to video
i've see i had seen the first one a
couple of times but i don't think that
i've ever seen the sequel so we're gonna
do dark man today tomorrow we're gonna
do part two and then tuesday we're gonna
do part three uh because i wanted to
watch the whole trilogy i liked dark man
it was a artistic movie
good story i mean this was kind of this
is a transitional film for sam raimi
because since this was 1990 he was just
coming off still being kind of like an
indie filmmaker like all his evil dead
stuff and everything like that so this
was kind of like his big
big his first big studio film like
working with uh with hollywood studio
um and what he had been trying to do for
a really long time um he had been
wanting to make
batman or he was trying to get the
rights to batman uh or the shadow
because he was real into like old comic
books and he couldn't secure the rights
to those
uh which kind of pissed him off a little
bit and so he's like well [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna make my own superhero movie
so i'm gonna invent my own original uh
superhero and he kind of wanted to base
it on
a lot of kind of like universal monster
type stuff uh you know there's gonna be
like a little bit of uh phantom of the
opera hunchback of notre dame um that
kind of stuff but then also kind of
filtered through
you know your regular like comic book
type
of story it's definitely a comic book
movie oh yeah and uh i think it's a
great movie uh you'd i didn't realize it
was sam raimi but now that she mentioned
it
me re-watching i was like oh yeah
there's a hell of a lot of [ __ ] evil
dead
yeah with some of the crazy it's not as
crazy as evil dead like with all those
wacky kind of like movements and stuff
but it does have a lot of that real
fluid
camera work that he would bring in
because he did spider-man later
obviously like he got he was very
successful but and and the special
effects are not realistic but they're
artistic
they're real artistic i like them
they're from the time they've aged well
yeah i mean there's a couple of the and
this kind of happens on every movie from
this time period but there's kind of a
couple of like the matte shots and
things like that like green screen and
stuff that don't really look that good
but like i said it's not just this movie
every movie from that from 1990 before
that like that had green screen like it
doesn't look that good because it looks
kind of like washed out or whatever so
you have that in in here a little bit
but i will say that like the makeup work
on this is amazing um it's just i don't
know this is just like a cool movie it's
just a fun movie because you have to
think that
it's maybe hard for people to uh that
you know didn't grow up in this time
period to understand but it's like prior
to this you had
comic book movies
but a lot of them weren't taken all that
seriously i mean tim burton's batman was
kind of the first one that
you know actually sort of took the
character series or seriously or kind of
made it more like the actual comic books
were
um
so it was kind of like a new thing
and this one i kind of feel like took
took it like a step farther because this
one's still like a fun movie and there's
humor in it but it's actually pretty
dark and it's pretty gruesome like
there's a lot of it's very violent yeah
uh you know i think it's r-rated i'm
pretty sure yeah and and [ __ ] dark
man himself is kind of like uh he's a
downer i mean that [ __ ] is crazy
his face is [ __ ] up
yeah i mean he can't help it that's just
like what happened to him
it drove him crazy
well it wasn't so much that it was yeah
well it was just it was the process of
them fixing him right turning the fire
that he went through and everything it's
great it's a great story yeah i can see
we talked about it's a lot like family
opera yeah a fan of the app well that's
what he was i mean he was really into
like i said old universal monster movies
and he's like he wanted to do something
like that but like a superhero he's a
little bit like the shadow too
yeah and that was one of the movies that
was one of the characters that he was
trying to get and remember they made
that movie of the shadow and i remember
it really not being all that good wasn't
one of the bald ones in that yeah the
shadow was great it had a great look
yeah it was cool looking yeah it should
have been a lot better than it was
but no it looked great it had a lot of
really good ideas in it
i think the problem i think the problem
with the shadow was the villain the
villain wasn't a compelling villain
i'd have to see it again it's been like
years and years and years yeah it was uh
genghis khan genghis khan was the
villain
and it just it didn't
didn't really work yeah he needed a much
better feeling
so yeah so this movie uh originally and
i kind of wish that this had happened
but you know no shade on liam neeson for
being uh the lead in this but originally
sam raimi wanted his homie bruce
campbell uh to play the lead
but the studio thought that bruce
campbell wasn't famous enough or wasn't
you know couldn't carry a whole film by
himself which
okay um but yeah he did now bruce
campbell does have like a cameo at the
very end
and he said i was watching like a little
clip of an interview with him earlier
and he said he did some of the voice
over work as well he's like you know
when they show this movie on tv and they
have to like dub out the swearing like
with other words he's like so that's me
like you know what i mean like if
somebody said [ __ ] or [ __ ] or whatever
and they just say you know
crap or dang or something like that he's
like that's my voice but yeah so uh so
he did that so that's kind of a shame
because i love bruce campbell but you
know
now liam neeson he's pretty i've
forgotten how young he [ __ ] was in
this movie this was kind of before
he was because now you say liam neeson
and he's been like all in those already
action movies is mostly what he's known
for like taken and all that kind of
stuff and uh but this was before that he
had kind of done a bunch of different
sort of roles so this was kind of his
first action role and he was actually
kind of excited about doing it like
working at all the makeup and stuff even
though it took [ __ ] forever to put on
but he'd never done anything like that
before so he like thought it was like
kind of cool because it was like a
challenge and i will say that i really
do like the makeup in this particularly
how it looks like the teeth or like the
skull and it's like the outside i think
that looks really cool
but uh but yeah so the story of this
is
uh liam neeson is a scientist
and he's working on
he's making like a synthetic skin and
it's for burn victims
which will really come in handy later on
like considering what happens
so he's working on that but he can't get
it to like work quite right because and
he can't figure out why he's like well i
make a nose and then aft it's stable for
like 99 minutes and then it like starts
to melt which obviously would be a
little bit embarrassing if that was your
actual nose so there's that
and you can't figure out like why that's
happening so there's that going on
meanwhile his girlfriend who is an
attorney
who's played by frances mcdormand
she is uh she has found evidence of some
skullduggery like at the one of the
businesses that she's uh you know kind
of doing lawyering for or whatever she
found this memo that's like for bribes
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
now uh she makes the perhaps unwise
decision to go to the ceo or what the
[ __ ] ever of this company and say hey i
found this memo that's about these
bribes and maybe you want to look into
this and he's like oh yeah that um
let's just uh pretend we never saw that
and then it turns out that the ceo of
this company has this whole
gang of
thugs and hoodlums and assassins and
whatnot that'll just go and kill anybody
that gets in the way of this project
that they're doing
so
that's basically what happens and that's
how dark man becomes dark man is that
she actually i guess they did they live
in the lab or i guess she was over at
his house like at the lab and she left
some of her [ __ ] over there including
this memo that all these thugs want to
get hold of and
the scientist uh dr payton he doesn't
have anything uh or dr westlake peyton's
his first name but he doesn't have he
doesn't know anything about that
but
the thugs come to his lab and are
basically like where's that memo he's
like what the [ __ ] are you even talking
about i don't know what that is that's
my girlfriend [ __ ] and they kill his
assistant which is horrible and then
they [ __ ] his face all up like they
throw him into acid and they beat his
ass and everything like that and then
they blow his [ __ ] up
the whole lap
now he goes flying out the
i love that shot yeah
it does it's amazing i [ __ ] love it
like because it's i love this because i
really like the tone like i said it's
very violent and it's very like it takes
it seriously but not so seriously that
it's not still like a good time like it
still has over-the-top comic book
elements but not so much that it's
ridiculous i think it like strikes a
really fine line yeah
not realism
not really
it but it is credible that's the way i
can say it you're like we'll see you oh
yeah okay well he goes flying out of
that [ __ ] fireball
it's obvious it's pretty awesome yeah
it's obvious that it was fake but you're
not really sure what they did to fake it
it just looked cool
it looked cool looking real cool
but uh no
it's a good movie um some people were
saying that he remembers that uh who's
that they're saying this that the
phantom
and uh
and the shadow yeah yeah
uh
comic book films back when i remember
the shadow the phantom or something they
weren't that good yeah yeah and dick
tracy yeah dick tracy i remember that
being not that great the thing is though
is if you go back and watch them they
weren't as bad as you remembered them
the standards were higher back then
expectations were higher
the phantom was actually pretty good the
shadow was pretty good too
like they didn't really know what to do
with comic book movies back then i kind
of feel like they were
i don't think they were entirely taking
them seriously it's almost kind of like
they were they wanted to make them for
kids but then there was like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in there that probably was not for
kids and it's like i don't know it's
just they they seemed very a lot of them
seemed tonally strange like they looked
cool yeah but i think they didn't really
know like what balance to strike between
taking it seriously or just making it
like a ridiculous farce of a movie
the shadow did okay i think it didn't
really make its money back but i think
it did okay
i think that well maybe that's not but i
guess that that's two separate things
and if it didn't make his money back it
didn't do okay uh yeah no
maybe it made its money back i remember
it doing okay
um
i enjoyed it though
uh there were certain aspects of it that
were really good but it just didn't
quite deliver and i think it had to do
with the bad guy it was a good idea
you got a guy who has psychic abilities
all right he can make you think he
disappeared you could make he could make
you think he looked [ __ ] more of a
badass than he actually was
he could make you think you couldn't see
him but he was just this dude dressed up
in this [ __ ] badass 40s outfit with a
couple of 45s a couple of 1911s
and he was just
kind of like batman in a way
but a psychic
you could do a lot with that and they
they had it that was the right look
i'm not sure that was the maybe the bald
one shouldn't have been
maybe he shouldn't have been the shadow
i don't know
but i think that would have worked too i
think the problem was the villain
well i haven't seen i haven't seen that
movie in a long time so i remember the
villain not being incredible i just
remember not liking it all that much i
remember the villain being very
cartoonish and not really all that
recommend not that now the phantom on
the other hand
i think that bombed i saw that later on
on on vhs and enjoyed it i liked it but
i got to see that one again too
it's just
this era of the 90s
comic book movies were coming in and i'm
not sure they exactly knew how to do
them well yeah that's what i was saying
they still don't really know how to do
them they still [ __ ] them up
well at least they take them like i said
at least they take them more seriously
nowadays as like you know an epic
mythology and they're not like just
making jokes about it joker was great
[ __ ] evidently this last batman
this last super uh spider-man was
supposed to be great i didn't see it but
they said it was fun
and this news batman i've heard mixed
things
all in all they say the new the new
batman is acceptable but we'll see we'll
see we'll see grampur's hammer says true
story in 1990 granthar worked at it he's
always he's referring himself to the
third person from now on yeah which
that's it makes me laugh every single
time uh grantham worked at a summer camp
in ontario canada after the campers left
for the season sam raimi came to visit
and gave grampa a fifth of crown royal
upon arrival damn what a nice man yes
sam frankie always seemed like pretty
fun you know what i mean
uh slasher fred then says frances
mcdormand who played peyton's girlfriend
later played the sheriff in the movie
fargo and actually i think i said this
to you last night we were watching it
when you know because i had forgotten
she was in it and i was just like oh man
this makes me want to watch fargo again
because i [ __ ] love that movie
granthar's hammer also said larry drake
who plays uh robert durant in this one
of the villains yeah yeah uh was later
in dr giggles which is probably what
he's best known as which is crazy
because you see it again prior to this
because he looking at him in dark man
and looking at him doctor giggles and
stuff he looks like a bad guy yeah but
prior to this i had forgotten he was on
la la
and he usually played like good guys
and so i think this might have been his
first villain role please correct me if
i'm wrong but it's just like funny
because when you look at his face you're
like oh yeah that dude's like could
totally type cast his villains but he
wasn't this was like his first battle i
got to see dr giggles again i haven't
seen that for a long time either and
that was enough yeah i remember liking
it too and that was like another one
that i kind of wanted to rewatch but
yeah he's like um he's like a gangster
and this he's kind of like a like an
assassin for hire essentially like he's
like the muscle and he has like a gang
of people that go and he has a thing
where he snaps people's fingers off with
his like cigar cutter dude
which uh is pretty [ __ ] up and he
keeps them like he has a collection in a
very nice like wooden box like he opens
it at some point there's all these
separate fingers in there all the
gangster characters are good in this
remember the heavyset ball dude with the
[ __ ] tattoo on his head they threw
out the window i remembered him since
back in those days yeah that's right
with the little
dagger tattoo on the top the chinese mob
boss okay you win remember that guy yeah
in the restaurant yeah there's there's
some good iconic
gangster characters in this this is a
great movie this is a great movie i had
a really good time like rewatching this
but yeah so where was i in the plot okay
so uh yeah so he gets blown out the
window that's where we got distracted he
gets blown out the window and then
obviously everybody thinks he's dead
because they said all they found was an
ear but then meanwhile they find this
dude in the river who doesn't have any
id and it's him uh you know obviously uh
but you know since he didn't have any id
he came in as a john doe
and so they bring him into the hospital
and they do this experimental uh [ __ ] on
him
for burn victims and
also a cameo in there by jenny agather
who plays the doctor she's like in one
scene and she's like talking about the
procedure that they're doing on them
which is experimental and she's saying
yeah basically what they're doing is
they're cutting all the
nerves so he doesn't feel any pain which
seems good but
sometimes probably not so good but
they're doing that so he doesn't have
all the pain from the burns and
they said but one of the side effects of
this experimental treatment is that uh
his emotions are heightened particularly
anger so he's like and it makes him kind
of like super strong like not it's not
like hulk he doesn't like hulk out or
anything but it does make him like
stronger than a regular person and uh
and he has a tendency to like go into
rages which he does at some point so uh
he so he basically goes back and finds
another lab
and kind of cobbles together a new lab
looks very much like frankenstein's uh
you know mad lab and i love it i love
the set design that they did in there
like an old warehouse
and he is able to put together like all
his lab again and start making the skin
and so he can only so the skin like just
destabilizes after 99 minutes um if you
go out in the sun like if you're in the
dark it'll be okay like it'll still be
stable but as soon as you go in the
light it's photosensitive actually i
think it's not just sun it's any kind of
light uh then it'll start melting off
your face but what he starts to do is to
get revenge on all the gangsters that
like uh
killed him or you know whatever
and killed his assistant he decides he's
gonna start making
replicas of their faces and then he's
gonna go [ __ ] up their [ __ ] so that's
kind of like where the original idea i
think that sam raimi had he wrote a
short story that was called the dark man
and he's like i liked the idea of a guy
who could just like take other people's
like make other people's faces and put
faces on himself and then he could let
go and cause chaos and that kind of yeah
this allows him to be a doppelganger yes
that's really what yes
and it allows him to make other people
drop the gaggers because he could put
somebody's face on somebody else
he does that too yeah he does that at
one point too so there's like layers of
like faces on there to make some make
one enemy look like another enemy and
send him out there so he he he does have
special abilities
yeah and it's just kind of a thing and i
like too that this kind of has
the love story at the heart of it i like
that it's in there but it's not like
overdone
um and it's kind of like tragic because
because of the way he's sort of [ __ ]
up look like he's he has like skinned
like masks of his actual face that he
made like from photos so he can put him
on sometimes but they kind of melt off
if he gets any light on him after a
little while so most of the time he's
just kind of like walking around with
like you know bandages over like the
invisible man
um
and there's kind of a thing too where
his girlfriend is actually she says oh
i'll love you no matter what you look
like but
he's kind of like doubtful about that
and he's like and also i have this
[ __ ] ragey [ __ ] going on um and he's
like i'm basically like turning into a
monster and he doesn't want to expose
her to that so basically he's just like
i have to go and be
so he just you know he kind of wanders
off into the sunset looking like bruce
campbell at the very end because he
doesn't want her to get hurt by being in
proximity to him because there's a thing
at the end where when he fights the main
like ceo the the [ __ ] guy that owns
the company and they're up on this like
tall like steel
thing of a building
and uh so they're fighting and he's like
going to drop the guy off and the guy's
like you're you know you're too nice a
guy no he doesn't say that but he's like
you know you you can't do it you don't
have the balls to like drop me off and
you know you wouldn't be able to live
with yourself and he's just like bye you
know what i mean which like i said
you know you could make an argument that
it's like yeah that's turned you as
monstrous as like the bad guys but it's
like the bad guys were
pricks that guy was a complete prick
they were doing illegal [ __ ] um they had
it coming i really don't think that's
like the same thing at all it's not like
he's killing innocent women and children
or anything like that he's killing bad
guys so i don't know i'm not bothered by
it but anyway um so i don't know like
where i haven't seen the second one or
the third one so i don't know where it's
gonna go from that the second one is
called
uh i think it's called the return of
robert durant and i'm like well that
would be quite a trick him returning
because he got blown up in a helicopter
real good like at the end of this but
like helicopter [ __ ] hit and honestly
that
sequence pretty good where um where it
was i don't know if it was liam neeson
or the stunt man i'm sure it was
probably a stunt man hanging from that
[ __ ] helicopter and they're like
slinging that [ __ ] and he's like hanging
from a hook and he's like slinging all
around the [ __ ] building and stuff
and most of that did not absolutely not
look fake
yeah um
they're dragging the helicopter from the
back of the truck yeah it looked good i
mean that was a really good [ __ ]
stunt yeah and then they crashed the
helicopter into and like i said if i
don't know if that was real if they did
it with miniatures managers i think it
was probably miniatures but if it was it
looked really good yeah and i'm just
saying a lot of the shots where
they were flying the helicopter around
and that guy was hanging off there a lot
of that looked real if it was fake or
green screen it didn't look like it so
i'm not really sure but yeah that was
like a really really good sequence but i
don't yeah i don't see how robert durant
could come back after that i guess we'll
figure it out like in the second one
they'll find a way they'll find a way to
bring him back
liam nielsen
no he didn't come back well because at
that point um after he did dark man
um he kind of then he went on to do like
schindler's list and stuff and he was
like nominated for oscars and stuff and
he's not gonna do it directed dvd right
yeah horror movie or like action movie i
guess he was like busy doing
important stuff so you know what i mean
so it's you know no shade like i said
but yeah so
yeah i had not seen this movie for many
many years and so i was kind of excited
to rewatch it it's like and i for a
second i had forgotten that it was a sam
raimi film and then i was just like oh
yeah that's right and i don't know i
just like i see it just goes to show
that you don't have to make
you know he wanted to make a superhero
movie he couldn't get the rights to the
superhero movies that he wanted to do so
he said [ __ ] it i'm just gonna make my
own superhero make up your own superhero
and then he made a movie about it and
yeah and it worked yeah you could
actually probably um
the dark man franchise could probably be
revived
actually you could you could make more
movies based on this
you probably could they actually they
did well they did a comic book series
they've done um you know they've done uh
you know toy figures and stuff like that
uh they actually did a tv pilot
um but the show didn't get picked up
that was a while back
um so it is still i think it has enough
of a cult following
and sam raimi has enough of a name
that i think they could probably do
something with it if it was done well
and it would probably have to be done by
samurai
yeah that's uh and i'm not really sure i
don't know if sam raimi would still be
interested in returning to the franchise
i mean it is his character and he can
make it right
but yeah i think that's what really
works with this one it's like well you
got good actors in it and
you know and it's a good story like i
said it's still got it's got fun
elements in it and it's got kind of that
fun a little bit of that crazy kind of
like sam raimi like energy in it and the
crazy visuals a little bit but it's
still
sort of grounded in reality and it's
still like pretty violent and pretty
gruesome like the makeup was kind of
gruesome and like some of the people
getting killed was kind of gruesome yeah
so i thought it was like a good i don't
know it was just like a really good tone
i thought the dark man property kind of
always reminded me of
of the um robocop property i would say
they were about just as great
the first movies being the best
um i don't remember too much about the
second dark man i remember it being okay
i don't remember the third one at all
yeah i don't think i saw the second one
or the third one yeah but we're gonna
watch those but the first dark man one
was i would say as great
as robocop won
would you agree i mean it's a totally
different kind of movie totally i'm
talking about in terms of greatness yeah
because it's around the same era robocop
was first but it was still the
the era of practical effects
and still the era of a movie needed good
writing and that a movie needed really
good editing
and uh
when i was watching dark man at
when i saw dark man when it came out at
the end of it i was impressed i was like
yeah
and and it kind of i thought it was as
good as robocop won
you know
yeah that's quite a recommendation yeah
coming from tom yeah thought it was as
good as robocop
hugo of a monster says uh face swapping
is some mission impossible [ __ ] yeah
that's right um and he says the
advantage of dark man is that he can be
any actor yeah see that's what i mean
because he could have just made a face
because his face was all [ __ ] up at
the beginning so it's like he could just
keep making new faces you know what i
mean
grantham's hammer then says sam raimi
later made a great movie called a simple
plan that is indeed a great movie it's
actually based on a novel by scott smith
who also wrote the ruins um the book is
also fantastic and uh the movie was very
very good i had forgotten that sam raimi
had made that as well and that's another
one that i have to rewatch because it's
been a long time since i watched that
then grantor said liam says he hates his
performance in schindler's list grampa
thinks it's one of the best ever in all
of filmed him i wonder why
yeah that's well you know you know how
people are like actors creative people
any kind of people they're just kind of
like
oh well yeah you're over critical of
your own [ __ ] i mean most of the time
honestly i kind of think you should
because that makes you be better at
stuff anybody that's just like cocky and
everything i do is amazing is not going
to be any good usually
but uh yeah so there's that i haven't
seen schindler's list in a long time
either but i remember like really really
i mean that's a pretty like devastating
and awesome movie i think i saw that in
the theater now that i'm thinking about
it this one i this one
dark man i don't think i saw in the
theater i very well might have because
this was right around the time period
when i was going and seeing a bunch of
[ __ ] at like the the crappy stinky
dollar theater yeah like for cheap
entertainment so i very well could have
um
but i don't remember i think i might
have seen it on cable like afterward or
i might have rented it like a year or
two later and i remember liking it but
then i sort of forgot about it after a
while but i've kind of like revisited it
every now and then like over the years
and
watching it last night i was like man i
forgot how much i like this movie
you know
yeah and i feel like i mean i guess it
has a cult following people still talk
like oliver harper did a show about it
there's a couple other horror channels
that did uh
kind of long
breakdowns of it so it does have its uh
have its fans but yeah so i because
shutter had added all three of them i
decided well let's just do all three of
the movies actually you said let's do
all three of the movies that'll cover
all three days this week of the movie
reviews
so you know so we watched dark man last
night tonight we're gonna watch part two
and we'll talk about that one tomorrow
and then we'll talk about the third one
on tuesday and then on wednesday
speaking of phantom of the opera that
was the topic that won for the main
episode show which we're very excited
about because it was tom's idea and when
he was talking about it i said oh that
sounds like a great [ __ ] idea for a
show let's put that in the poll
and i was very happy it won by quite a
large margin
so yes that's we're going to do like the
regular episode on as well so it's like
a whole phantom of the opera week i
guess kind of
so that's kind of neat um you have
anything else that you need to
uh discuss nope
nope
[Laughter]
all right so uh yeah so thanks everybody
for dropping by today
and have a good rest of your weekend and
we will see you guys again tomorrow
evening talking about dark man 2
and uh have a good sunday
bye